Boris Johnson emerges from the British
elections of the massive mandate
Democrats and Republicans play Rock'em
Sock'em robots during impeachment and we
checked the mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show the Ben Shapiro
show is sponsored by expressvpn your
data is your business protected and
expressvpn calm slash Ben well the
markets have been going up and that's
great but there's a lot of volatility in
the markets these days and the fact is
that banks control the world money
supply and that means that governments
are constantly having to play this game
where they're inflating currency or
deflating currency what if you just want
like a stable asset to make sure that
some of your assets are protected well
that would be gold and the people you
should talk to are the people over at
Birch gold you're a smart investor well
now is the time to get in touch with the
folks at Birch gold have a conversation
with the Birch gold expert and see if
precious metals make sense for your
family today they're putting out an
offer I've never seen it's the silver
stocking stuffer event when you contact
Birch gold group this month to buy
precious metals once you complete your
purchase before December 20th so time is
running out Birch gold will send you
free silver it's a great stocking
stuffer or Hanukkah gift wasn't I know
the folks at Birch gold they've been
with me since the very beginning I've
asked them lots of questions they've
given me lots of the answers and you
should do the same thing if you're
interested in investing in precious
metals they're the people that I trust
and I think that you'll trust them too
once you talk to them go check them out
right now over at Birch gold calm and
also text my name Ben - 47 47 47 again
my name Ben - 47 47 47 when you open
your account with gold group today you
get it free 100 percent silver you can
even get a copy of their no obligation
free information kit again it's a smart
thing to diversify and some of their
money should be in precious metals text
my name Ben - 47 47 47 claim your
eligibility for the special offer today
text Ben - 47 47 47 well great britain
slow clap for you slow clap for you
today because jeremy corbyn who is a
vicious communist anti-semite not only
lost the election last night he's going
to he's going to drop his leadership in
the Labor Party which is just a
wonderful wonderful result and this was
a big gamble by Boris Johnson and the
Conservative Party so Boris Jon
had basically brought Britain to an
election on the basis that he didn't
have a mandate to push forward with
brexit now two years ago there was a
vote on brexit sorry actually is in 2016
so it would have been three years ago
there was a vote on brexit and the
people of Britain decided that they were
not going to go along with the --use
over-regulation and centralization of
power and this came as a shock to the
world media the world media expected
that the Brits they'd be sophisticated
enough to just go along with the EU and
he used free immigration policies that
Britain would swallow the crow of having
to deal with Angela Merkel's individual
German immigration policies and then
because of free transport everybody
would be able to move across state lines
into Britain that Britain would be fine
with the over-regulation from Brussels
every aspect of British life being
controlled by unelected bureaucrats in
Brussels and it turns out that the Brits
were not okay with that and they voted
that way in the largest single
referendum in the history of the nation
well ever since then the government of
Britain has been trying to stop brexit
from happening so Theresa Mick have put
him forward brexit proposal after brexit
proposal but she didn't have enough in
an electoral mandate in order to get
that done because members of her own
party some of them thought that the
brexit deal was too easy on the EU
others of it thought that it was too
harsh on the EU labour was standing
against Brett said there just was not
that they shouldn't have the numbers and
so she ended up leaving the prime
ministership she was widely perceived
not to really want to do brexit in the
first place and Boris Johnson replaced
her the very colourful former Mayor of
London Boris Johnson took over pledging
that he was gonna get Bret's it done and
he tried to ram it through he tried to
suspend Parliament at one point in order
to shorten the period that Labour would
have to stop him from ramming it through
in the end he was unable to do that and
so he called new elections it was a
risky move because of the fact is that
the British people could have said
listen retired of all this brexit stuff
let's have a second referendum and this
time we will cut against brexit and we
will stand with the Labour Party well
instead labour is handed a crushing blow
just a massive massive blow as the
Conservative Party in Britain walks with
an 80 seat majority in the in the houses
Parliament which is an incredible
incredible thing and it really it truly
is that it's the biggest landslide
against ley
I believe in the country's history it's
it's this incredible incredible blow to
what is an incredibly powerful party in
Britain and it's not just a referendum
about brexit obviously although was the
British people saying listen we've said
over and over you guys you got to get it
done just get it done what do we have to
do here get it done it was in part that
in part it was a direct referendum on
the leadership of Jeremy Corbyn who is
indeed as I say a communist and an
anti-semite who has never met an
anti-semitic dictator he does not love
according to the AP Prime Minister Boris
Johnson's Conservative Party who's won a
thumping majority of seats in Britain's
Parliament a decisive outcome to a
brexit dominated election that should
allow Johnson to fulfil his plan to take
the UK out of the EU next month with 642
of the 650 results declared on Friday
the Conservatives had 358 seats and the
main opposition Labour Party had 203
that is a blowout a blowout
Johnson said it looked like the
Conservatives had a powerful new mandate
to get brexit done
this makes Johnson the most electorally
successful Conservative leader since
Margaret Thatcher it was a disaster for
left-wing Labour leader Jeremy Corbyn
who faced calls for his resignation
even as the results poured in meanwhile
the Scottish National Party won almost
50 of Scotland's 59 seats up from 35
that will embolden their demands for a
new referendum on Scottish independence
but Parliament has to go along with that
Parliament is not going to go along with
a new referendum on Scottish
independence the centrist pro-eu Liberal
Democrats took only about a dozen seats
and Liberal Democratic leader Joe
Swinson stepped down after losing in her
own Scottish constituency the
Conservatives took a swath of seats in
the post-industrial northern English
towns that were long labour strongholds
Labour's vote held up better in London
that was pretty much the only place
where labour held up the decisive
conservative showing vindicates
Johnson's decision to press for
Thursday's early election which was held
nearly two years ahead of schedule he
said that if conservatives won a
majority he would get Parliament to
ratify his brexit divorce deal and take
the UK out of the EU by the current
January 31st deadline Johnson said the
historic election quote gives us now in
this new government the chance to
respect the democratic will of the
British people to change this country
for the better and to unleash the
potential of the entire people of this
country pretty much everybody turned
away from labor labor economy spokesman
Sean McDonald said I think brexit has
dominated his dominated everything by
the looks of it we thought other issues
could cut through and there'd be a wider
debate from the
instead clearly wasn't well yes brexit
was the big issue the other issues that
jeremy corbyn is a nut job and everybody
in britain understood that jeremy corbyn
was a nut job the chief rabbi of england
came out and said that Jews should not
vote for this anti-semitic party
astonishing astonishing and you've
already seen the pressure have its toll
Jeremy Corbyn announcing last night that
the election had gone quite poorly for
him and then announcing that he was
going to step down from leadership of
labour also make it clear that I will
not lead the party in any future general
election campaign I will discuss with
our party to ensure there is a process
now of reflection on this result and on
the policies that the party will take
going forward and I will lead the party
during that period to ensure that
discussion takes place and we move on
into the future okay and everybody
cheers this is in his constituency so
the way that it works in Britain is that
everybody who's in Parliament obviously
has to be a member of parliament so the
leader of a parliamentary party has to
be a member of parliament you have to be
elected in your own constituency so
Boris Johnson announced his election
victory basically in a congressional
district in the way that it would kind
of be the the analogy in the United
States would be as though in Congress
the biggest party in Congress then had a
leader and that part that leaders party
the the party leader ended up becoming
presidents of the United States it's
sort of like that in Britain that's how
the parliamentary system works so that
means that everybody is announcing from
their congressional district or from
their constituency in this case what was
wonderful about that video where Jeremy
Corbyn is announcing that he will no
longer leave the Labour Party in general
elections a couple of things are
wonderful about this one Britain has
this incredibly great tradition where
all it takes is basically 50 anything
like 50 50 pounds or 500 pounds or
something laughs I think it's 500 pounds
in order to stand for Parliament if you
do then you get to stand on the stage as
the parliamentary election results are
read so behind Boris John so behind
Jeremy Corbyn is standing a dude in a
white coat and a goofy hat which is
pretty spectacular and behind Boris
Johnson by the way in his constituency
well it was Lord Buckethead and Elmo
which is always wonderful because
honestly democracy shouldn't take
themselves
seriously human endeavors are all
ridiculous and this is just proof of it
but the best part of this is the Jewish
guy in the yarmulke who presumably was
campaigning with the Conservative Party
who is standing behind Boris Johnson and
smiling broadly as Jeremy Corbyn
announced it's not gonna be leading the
Labour Party and good for the Brits good
for the Brits for rejecting this piece
of garbage Jeremy Corbyn and he is he is
awful in every possible way he is awful
not only is he basically a communist on
policy but he happens to be a vicious
anti-semite and he has for years liam
had a piece in the tower org back
in 2015 describing how corbin hobnob
with anti-semites corbin said in 2009
quote it will be my pleasure in my honor
to host an event in parliament where our
friends from Hezbollah will be speaking
I've also invited friends from Hamas to
come and speak as well unfortunately the
Israelis would not allow them to travel
here so it's going to be only friends
from Hezbollah and Corbin then said he
didn't mean that they were just his
friends just meant like friends
collectively and the Labour Party was
rife with anti-semites who had entered
the halls of power thanks to Jeremy
Corbyn again none of this was new but
the British people were not going to
embrace that and good for them good for
them now did any of that stop Alexandre
Ocasio Cortes from endorsing Jeremy
Corbyn the fact that he is a radical
leftist was never met a dictator he
doesn't love and has never met a Jew
hater he didn't become friends with AOC
tweeted out a video she tweeted this
address before the election from Jeremy
Corbyn this video is about the UK but it
might as well have been produced about
the United States the hoarding of wealth
by the few is coming at the cost of
people's lives the only way we change is
with a massive surge of new voters at
the polls UK vote they did and ended
poorly for them wasn't just a OC calling
on the Brits to show up in favor in
favor of Jeremy Corbyn it was also
Bernie Sanders who Bernie Sanders is
team the the head of Bernie Sanders's
national organization Clare Sandberg
tweeted out the Bernie team says vote
Labour solidarity with all the folks
knocking on doors in the cold rain
getting out the vote for for the many
not the few so they and then it showed a
picture of people
Berni signs alongside people holding
Jeremy Corbyn for leader signs so openly
endorsing the anti-semites to get
absolutely smashed at the polls
spectacular if I do love the UK Guardian
which is beside itself this morning the
UK Guardian has an entire piece about
how the Russians stole the election for
Boris Johnson uh-huh uh-huh now the
disconnect between the polls and the
actual final election results are pretty
stunning because leading up to this
election there are a bunch of polls that
were done the media were covering this
thing is though it was very very tight
everybody was very nervous listen I had
calls from people who have hundreds of
employees in Britain and they were they
look somebody said this to me yesterday
they literally said as the polls were
happening they said if Jeremy Corbyn
became prime minister they were going to
remove the business from Britain and
there was just the reaction of the
British people to Jeremy Corbyn was
violently anti because he's awful and
that really helped Boris Johnson it also
helped Boris Johnson that a lot of
working-class Brits were sick of the
elitists in Britain telling them that
they had to listen to the elitists in
Brussels at the heads always have to
angle a Merkel's foreign policy and then
they had to then that that they had to
accept Sweden's social policy they were
not up for it according to the AP on the
whole labour tried to focus the campaign
away from brexit and on to its radical
domestic agenda they want to tax the
rich nationalized industries like
railroads and water companies and give
everyone in the country free internet
access it campaigned heavily on the
future of the National Health Service
it appears that was not enough to boost
Labour's fortune defeat spells the end
for Jeremy Corbyn a veteran socialist
who moved his party sharply to the left
after taking the helm in 2015 but who
now looks to have led his left of
central party to two electoral defeats
since 2017 he was also accused of
allowing anti-semitism to spread inside
the party labour members were pissed
the London Mayor Sadiq Khan who is a
member of labour he came out he said
jeremy corbyn's leadership his disaster
area khan has been quite critical of
corbin specifically because of Corbin's
opens Halloran's of anti-semitism inside
the party Sadiq Khan who's looking for a
leadership position in the labour party
he said this general election results is
nothing short of a catastrophe for the
Labour Party for London and for the UK
for the fourth general election in a row
the Labour Party has failed to put
forward a compelling case to the British
people it is no consolation that we
performed so much better here in London
we have fundamentally failed those that
most desperately need the help of a
Labour government to include the sick
the poorest the vulnerable are dedicated
activists at all
as ever I'm truly grateful for all their
hard work and then he just goes right
after Corbin with a steak knife if we
are truly honest with ourselves we knew
in our hearts that jeremy corbyn's
leadership was deeply unpopular with the
british people and that we were
extremely unlikely to form a Labour
government last night Labour's shocking
and repeated failure to tackle
anti-semitism
okay this criticism is coming from
inside the house and I just like to make
a note for the Democratic Party in
today's America guys you could do the
same thing to the anti-semites in your
own party you could say Ilmenau Myron
Rasheeda Talib you're not helpful by the
way it is worth noting that Rasheeda
Talib there is that Jersey City
anti-semitic shooting which by the way
could have been so much worse when I say
it could have been so much worse that I
mean six people died four people who
were good and the two shooters the
shooters apparently were actually aiming
for the site next door where there were
50 school-aged children studying
upstairs Jewish kids they actually shot
at the door and then when they couldn't
get in the door they went is the kosher
supermarket and shot that place up
Rasheeda Talib had tweeted out how
terrible the shooting was and blamed it
on white supremacist and it turns out it
was black Hebrew Israelites and then she
deleted the tweet she's not tweeted
anything about Jersey City I believe AOC
has not tweeted anything about Jersey
City Johan Omar my understanding is has
not tweeted anything about Jersey City
you know if you guys in the Democratic
Party don't want to go the way of Labor
then perhaps you ought to consider
tossing the radicals out of your own
party good for Sadiq Khan he says
Labor's shocking and repeated failure to
tackle anti-semitism and our inability
to put forward a credible and believable
set of priorities for governing have
made a major contribution to the scale
of this defeat brexit has accelerated a
fundamental shift in British politics
and rewritten our political map the full
extent of which is not yet fully
understood however labour now stands
more politically and culturally removed
than ever before from many of the people
our party was formed to represent and
that means asking ourselves some very
difficult questions the next five years
are full of grave challenges we'll leave
the European Union on Boris Johnson's
terms our union with Scotland is in
peril we will face damaging and
far-reaching changes to our economy and
public services from this hard right
Tory government the Labour Party will
have to change fundamentally in order to
rise to these challenges and confront
the new political reality that we face
Jeremy Corbyn has said he will stand
down this simply must now happen quickly
but the changes we have to make will not
end with his leadership that is damn
well true ok it's not just going to be
Jeremy Corbyn the entire Labour Party
has to be purged of the Communists in
anti-semites if they wish to be
competitive again it is good for Western
civilization that Western parties not
embrace communism and Jew hatred so very
good result from Britain last night I'll
explain it in just one second what I
think this means for the United States
because people are taking lessons away
from this in the United States we'll get
to that in just one second first let's
talk about how easy it is to rack up
credit card debt so the fact is that
especially you're going shopping this
holiday season and somebody says open
the brand-new credit card and you'll get
a 20% off deal and so you're like okay
I'll open the brand new credit card next
thing you know not only have you open
the brand new credit card you've
overspent on the brand new credit card
and now you can't make the payment and
now you've entered the world of the
credit card companies where you're
getting charged those 20% monthly rates
like the crazy crazy rates where you
can't pay it off and suddenly the
accrued interest out numbers it out it
out ways the actual amount that you'd
spent on the credit card well there's
one way to get out of this and that is
be responsible and refinance that's at
right now one of the people the folks
helping you right now Lending Club calm
with Lending Club you can consolidate
your debt or pay off credit cards with
one fixed monthly payment Lending Club
so millions of people regain control of
their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans no trips to a
bank no high interest credit cards just
go to Lending Club calm you can tell
them about yourself and how much you
want to borrow and pick the terms that
are right for you if you're approved
your loan is automatically deposited
into that bank accounts in as little as
a few days go to Lending Club com slash
been you gotta get out of debt okay you
do not want that debt to dog you the
rest of your life go get out of debt
right now go to Lending Club com /ban
check it right in minutes borrow up to
40 grand
that's Lending Club calm /ban Lending
Club calm /ban all loans made by web
bank member FDIC Equal Housing lender
okay so what does this mean for the
United States well a lot of
conservatives today are saying a few
things one the disconnect between the
press and the people in Britain is just
as large in the United States the press
in Britain cannot believe this cannot
believe this and if you look at the UK
Guardian Today The Guardian is just
beside itself again they printed an
article in the UK Guardian today in
which they suggested that Boris Johnson
had won because the Russians helped him
cheat I mean this is one of my favorite
articles the headline over at the UK
Guardian which is sort of the the
equivalent of
Britain the nation maybe they say
winners and losers few bright notes on a
grim night for labour yes yeah so the
media in Britain is very much
disconnected for this mission mainstream
media and Britain very much disconnected
from the people and said they can't
believe that a lot of the Labour
strongholds those white working-class
strongholds in the north of England
voted in favor of the Conservative Party
and one of the big factors here is that
Nigel Faraj made the correct decision to
get out of the way so Nigel Faraj is
brexit party was slated to win some of
these seats and he went to Boris Johnson
and it was obvious that Johnson in order
to get brexit done needed that actual
though the votes that were gonna go to
the Braxtons party to go to the
Conservative Party
Faraj did the right thing stepped out of
the way and now brexit is going to get
done so good for a national Faraj so the
media disconnect is very similar to that
in the United States the media in the
United States cannot believe that there
is a single human being in the United
States who would vote for Donald Trump
and that means that some of the polls
are probably a little bit wrong
okay the polls on this thing we're not
particularly good the polls on Trump may
not be all that great now I'm not a
person who discards poll data
wholesale I think you've got to take it
for what it's worth but when you talk to
conservatives when pollsters call them
sometimes they just don't answer the
questions the way they honestly believe
because they're screwing with the
pollsters because they don't trust the
people asking the poll questions very
often poll numbers are a referendum on
the people who are asking the questions
more than a referendum on the subject of
the questions so there is that the other
thing is that the populist appeal of
Boris Johnson is not off-putting to
people people in the in the British
media thought okay this Borgia he acts
like a clown Boris Johnson he drives
like trucks through walls and the truck
is labeled brexit on it and very
trumpian kind of stuff now there is a
difference between Boris Johnson and
Donald Trump which is that Boris Johnson
is an actual classic scholar like Boris
Johnson is a quasi philosopher if you
actually sit down and talk with Boris
Johnson dude is incredibly bright that's
not to say Trump is stupid but Johnson
is a quasi intellectual okay with all of
that said his effect is very much like
Trump's and the media don't get it
the media are like why this is the sort
of clownish behavior why can't we have
the radical no I'm Chomsky college
professor Jeremy Corbyn in the United
States it's the same thing why can't we
have Elizabeth Warren who teaches
classes at Harvard Law School why can't
we be genteel the American people don't
care about that and one someone who
speaks blunt truths the same thing as in
Britain it is worth noting when I was
back in college at UCLA I took a course
on British politics and I remember
writing a paper specifically about the
close mirroring between the in between
the the outcomes of British elections
and the outcomes of American elections
basically Britain and the United States
tend to move politically in tandem when
Britain moves to the left the United
States tends to move to the left when
the United States moves to the right
Britain tends to move to the right it
tends to presage particular ships which
is why a lot of people saw a brexit as
sort of an indicator that Trump is gonna
do better than expected okay so this
should be scary for the Democrats in the
United States and also it should be a
wake up call the Democrats in the United
States it should be a wake up call that
when you guys skew too far to the left
the same way that Jeremy Corbyn skewed
too far to the left you're going to
leave the public behind remember the
folks in Britain they're a lot more used
to socialism than the folks in the
United States there's a lot more used to
socialist talk they're a lot more used
to big government than people in the
United States are the Democratic Party
is mirroring the Labour Party in Britain
but the public in America is not even as
left-wing as the public in Britain we
don't have a National Health Service so
for the Democratic Party to mirror that
is incredibly stupid
now lessons for the right one of the
things that is true about Boris Johnson
is that he basically made the campaign
about a couple of key issues right he
made about brexit and about stopping
Jeremy Corbyn that was basically Boris
Johnson's campaign he didn't make it
about reforming and and changing the NHS
he didn't make it
really about income inequality or tax
cuts or anything like that he focused on
one issue that he knew was pretty
popular with the British people and he
focused on the evils of his opposition
now Donald Trump did something like that
in 2016 he didn't campaign on
entitlement reform in fact he overtly
said that he was not going to change
entitlements he campaigned as a
quote-unquote moderate Republican now
the question is does his governing
record match that want on entitlements
it does or I mean he hasn't actually
changed entitlements to my great chagrin
he is he is governed as a conservative
on tax cuts on judges on parts of
foreign policy but he's not coming
particularly conservatively in terms of
spending and he's blown out the spending
and so you could see Trump running a
very similar campaign pointing to the
radical
have left and then pointing to his
economic record and saying do you want
that economic record to continue or not
well for him that means that the best
thing that could happen is that
Elizabeth Warren becomes the nominee or
Bernie Sanders who is overtaking
Elizabeth Warren in national polling
becomes the nominee it's the reason why
and Joe Biden knows this right this is
why Joe Biden today in the aftermath of
this thing is saying look at Britain do
you really think that the Democrats are
gonna be able to nominate their own
Jeremy Corbyn and that guy's gonna win
in the United States so Biden and his
allies are seizing on this Biden says
look what happens when the Labour Party
moves so far so far it's at left he said
that as the British election results
became clear now Bernie Sanders had
already endorsed Jeremy Corbyn Biden
said Boris Johnson is winning a walk he
predicted the pundits would say look
what happens when the Labour Party moves
so so far to the left it comes up with
ideas that are not able to be contained
in a rational basis quickly and he also
drew comparisons between Johnson and
Trump he says you're gonna see some
people saying my god Boris Johnson who
is kind of a physical and emotional
clone of the president is able to win
well yeah again I think that Boris
Johnson that that's selling Boris
Johnson quite a bit short but the
general point is well-taken and it is
true that centrist in the United States
are going to point to the radical move
of the Democratic Party and they're
going to say okay well do we want this
to look exactly like Britain is that is
this what we want
by the way it'd be a very good thing for
the country if the Democratic Party
would move somewhere closer to the
semblance of sanity that'd be quite a
good thing for for the American people
okay in just a second we're going to get
to the House of Representatives the
House Judiciary Committee has now passed
into articles of impeachment against the
presidents of the United States this is
a foregone conclusion we'll get to that
in just one second first every holiday
season I get ready to send a bunch of
packages to friends and family for
Hanukkah or I get sent off the the
Christmas cards to people you know the
Happy Holidays cards and everything and
very often that necessitates me taking
all the stuff and schlepping it in my
car well I got two kids under the age of
five and that means taking my kids put
him in the car having to figure out how
I with two hands I'm able to carry three
things one child here one child here and
then all of the packages here since I
don't have a third hand it's a giant
pain in the butt and since I am less
likely to grow a third hand than to just
do all this from home I recommend stamp
dot-com stamps.com brings all the
services of the US Postal Service
directly to your computer whether you're
a small office sending invoices or an
online seller shipping out products or
even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it and once your mail
is ready you just hand it to your mail
carrier or drop it in a mail box it's
really simple really easy and right now
they are offering a special deal there's
no risk with my promo code Shapiro's you
get a special offer it includes a
four-week trial plus free postage in the
digital scale no long term commitments
no contract using our code you will be
saving money and supporting the show
which is important to us in born to
stamps com go to stamps com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in Shapiro I personally use stamps
comm we use it here at daily wear at
your small business your large business
you personally stamps comm is a great
solution for you go to stamps comm enter
Shapiro stamps comm never go to the post
office again okay so meanwhile in the
United States the Democratic Party is
moving toward impeachment so today they
held a vote on impeachment in the House
Judiciary Committee they did this that
they were going to do this last night
the whole thing was theatrics over the
last 24 hours has basically been all of
these idiotic hearings in the House
Judiciary Committee for markup of the
impeachment charges they were never
gonna get marked out nothing was gonna
change because the majority the
Democrats don't care what the minority
the Republicans have to say in fact they
don't want any of those rules applied
and so this hearing turned into a quite
entertaining if completely useless
spectacle in the stupidity of these
impeachment hearings generally so this
morning the House Judiciary passed the
impeachment vote along completely
partisan lines here's what that sounded
like
mr. chairman there are 23 eyes and 17
nose the article is agreed to the
question now is an article 2 of the
resolution impeaching President Donald J
Trump believable so again this is this
is a bipartisan effort clearly the
Democrats are just worried about the
constitutional implications of Trump's
behavior now the Republicans are going
nuts over this and they're going nuts in
in very colorful fashion Mitch McConnell
who is the turtle list of turtles I mean
Mitch McConnell is not somebody to
overstate the cases listen this is not
happening there's no chance that Trump
has removed this is what Mitch McConnell
sounds like when he has agitated have
you ever seen a have you ever seen one
of those t-shirts that has the moods of
Darth Vader that's just the Darth Vader
mask like angry Darth Vader is the same
as happy to our theater that's Mitch
McConnell this is Mitch McConnell
agitated the case is so darn weak coming
over from the house we all know how it's
going to end there's no chance the
president's going to be removed from
office my hope is that there won't be a
single Republican who votes for either
of these articles of impeachment and
Shana wouldn't surprise me if we got one
or two Democrats it looks to me over in
the house the Republicans seem to be
solid and the Democrats seem to be
divided yes well that is certainly true
by the way representative Doug Collins
it was a great opportunity for Congress
people to put their names in the
headlines and that meant you got a lot
of colorful good TV a lot of Al Pacino
in and justice for all
right you're out of order this entire
Court is out of order here's Doug
Collins doing that Republican from
Georgia there's not a Democrat in this
room they should be happy about this the
solemn unity the solemn entity should be
on the death of this committees process
and procedures don't give me the solemn
entity about impeaching a president
you've been wanting to do that for a
long time you ought to take it and just
rejoice go at it because this is what
you wanted okay Jim Jordan did the same
thing the Congress person from Ohio he
said this process is rigged and rushed
because of what we have here are two
cases that you're about to see one is
the Republicans saying this process is
ridiculous this is all about you guys
going after Trump and then the Democrats
saying yeah it kind of is so here is Jim
Jordan you have a rigged and rushed
process when you don't have the facts
you have a rigged and rushed process
when you can't accept the will of the
American people and of course you have a
rigged and rushed process when you're
afraid that you can't beat the president
at the ballot box okay and that last
part is indeed the case the Democrats
are rushing the process because they
can't they think that Trump is likely to
win and given prevailing trends and as
will explain given some of the late
actions of President Trump and even the
last week
Trump's odds of winning are going up
fairly dramatically well we'll get to
why that is we'll get to the Republicans
versus the Democrats going at each
other's throats you know at least I
do not entertain we don't have Lord
Buckethead or Elmo here but we do have
the United States Congress Theo I give
you the United States Congress we'll get
to that in just one second first have
you ever had a situation where something
is broken down in your car and you need
a specific part and this has happened to
me before and then I head on over to
like autozone or I head over to one of
the other auto parts stores and I go
there and they don't have the right part
and so I have to schlep this dying car
over to another store and they don't
have a part either and I thought some I
think to myself okay well you know how
can I get the part that I actually need
without leaving my home I'm an inter
webs person well Rock Auto calm knows
that you two are at ins for Webb's
person and that means that you should be
looking at rockauto.com you got a
problem with your car rockauto.com is a
family business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years head on
over to rockauto.com shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they've got everything
from engine control modules and brake
parts to tail lamps motor oil even new
carpet whether it's for your classic or
your daily driver get everything you
need in a few easy clicks delivered
directly to your door the rockauto.com
catalog really really easy to navigate
you can quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle and filter by
brands specifications and prices get the
exact part delivered to your house so
you're not trying to schlep a
broken-down car to seven different auto
parts stores just to get a part that
isn't exact best of all prices at Rock
auto comm are always reliably both the
same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers they've got great
selection reliably low prices all the
parts your car will ever need
rockauto.com
head on over to Rock Auto calm right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck and right Shapiro's in there
how did you hear about us box so they
know that we sent you again rockauto.com
in please remember right Shapiro's in
there how did you hear about us box
because that helps them know that you
heard about us something they heard
about them on the show already we're
gonna get back to the the battle between
the democrats and the republicans and
then there is this insane piece in the
washington post that like there is no
way that this piece would ever be
written about group a group other than
jews i mean no way no way we'll get to
that in just one second first it is that
glorious time of the week when i give a
shout out to a daily water subscriber
today it's instagram or ben Widdowson
who's doing his best to change minds on
a very important subject in the picture
Ben is taking a swig from his majestic
leftist ears tumblr as he sits in the
hallway of his high school engaged in a
very worthwhile and civil
the caption reads round 1 of I'm
pro-life changed my mind was a success
thank you to phhs conservatives for
letting me run this table and voice my
opinions everyone who debated to watch
and everyone who showed up to watch and
everyone who debated me even if we
disagreed
I can't wait for round 2 can't wait to
hear more opinions hashtag leftist ears
tumblr a civility and conversation
excellent job then hope around to goes
just as well and enjoy those leftist
tears thanks for the pic keep up the
good work so why should you subscribe
because you too can have that left is
tears tumblr and right now by the way
let me remind you that you are able to
get a subscription at daily wire for 25%
off why should you do that not only did
you get this show and two additional
hours but you get discounts on all sorts
of great stuff you get to have AMAs with
me right you can ask me questions you
can be in our mailbag what we're gonna
do write all sorts of good stuff plus
you get the Sunday special on Saturday
this Sunday's special Franklin stops by
to talk about the power of language
here's a little bit of what that sounded
like
I've already been in 30 states I got
another three or four more to go before
we reach New Year's they do know how mad
we are I do you know how how this
ugliness is damned desire to be heard
not to listen not to learn but to be
heard how it's undermining so many
things and it doesn't have to be this
way
already so it's a great interview yeah I
think you'll really enjoy it really
pretty fascinating we go through all the
Republican candidates the Democratic
candidates everybody it's really good
you get all of those things I really get
all sorts of special privileges when you
become a member also the daily whereas
or in Amazon the perfect place for your
holiday shopping needs from our classic
facts don't care about your feelings
shirts which now 15% off so are hugely
popular zero barked thirty shirt and now
our brand new Santa's Santa Trump's hoax
hoax hoax sweatshirt
mhm check that out Merry Christmas you
will find plenty of goodies to make this
the best give gift-giving season ever
and if you buy this week your orders
will arrive just in time for Christmas
so head on over to Daley wire.com check
out our amazon store let the shopping
begin and again if you're not already a
subscriber you're missing out go to
daily wear comm slash subscribe for as
little as ten bucks a month you get our
articles ad free access to all of our
live broadcast our full show library
select bonus contents our exclusive
daily to our app pretty great feature if
you have not checked it out yet we are
the largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so as I say almost a complete waste of
time yesterday in the House Judiciary
Committee as the Democrats vote on two
articles of impeachment and the
Republicans militate against that Matt
Gaetz who again many of the more
colorful members of Congress had their
moments in the sunshine and their
moments in the sunshine yesterday Matt
gets a Florida he said this is obviously
bloodlust for Trump which it is time and
again they let us down in their claims
but one thing we know for certain is
that this was a sad and evitt ability I
had someone asked me recently do you
feel some sense of history some sense of
moment that you're about to vote on
impeachment and sadly I knew this time
was coming since the Democrats took
control of the House of Representatives
because they didn't lay out a plan to
appropriate for the budget work with us
on critical generational issues they set
out a plan for impeachment well that is
that is exactly right now the most
colorful moments of this entire thing
happened when Matt Gaetz went after
hunter Biden he was pointing out that it
should be kind of suspicious that hunter
Biden was obtaining these
extraordinarily lucrative jobs while
having a record that included busts on
drugs and all sorts of other problems
Matt get says that Hank Johnson of
Georgia I believe he the Democrat he
jumps in he says well you have a DUI
okay so it turned real Rock'em Sock'em
robots I will note that logically
speaking Matt Gaetz was elected to
Congress okay he was not selected
because his last name was gets he didn't
have a connection with the vice
presidents of the United States there is
an actual difference between being
elected in spite of a past DUI bata
O'Rourke and between being in a
situation where you obtain a $50,000 a
month job despite no history in the
industry despite no actual
qualifications because your last name is
Biden anyway here's Matt Gaetz versus
Hank Johnson this made a lot of
headlines yesterday and I don't want to
make light of anybody's substance abuse
issues I know the president's working
real hard to solve those throughout the
country but it's a little hard to
believe that burr yzma hired hunter
Biden to resolve their international
disputes when he could not resolve his
own dispute with Hertz rental car overly
believed in cocaine and a crack pipe in
the car the pot calling the kettle black
is not something that we should
do I don't know I don't know what
members if any have had any problems
with substance abuse been busted in DUI
I don't know but if I did I wouldn't
raise it against anyone on this
committee I don't think it's proper okay
so is that really you know is that
really a fair head the answer is of
course it really is not but that made a
lot of headlines because people standing
up to judge so all of this is just for
sham everybody everybody understands
this is just for show the Democrats were
going to ram this through no matter what
Nancy Pelosi was specifically asked
yesterday why if you are so confident
that Donald Trump committed an act of
bribery here is the basis for
impeachment didn't you just include
bribery is one of the impeachable
charges the obvious answer they don't
have the elements meaning they don't
have the evidence Nancy Pelosi just
skips right on by that just slides right
on my the question I myself I'm not a
lawyer sometimes I act like one not as
often as I act as a doctor I practice
medicine on the side without benefit of
diploma or two this is a decision that
was recommended by our working together
with our committee chairs our attorneys
and the rest so the articles are what
they are they're very powerful they're
very strong and they a continuation of a
pattern of misbehavior on the part of
the president very powerful and very
strong and also have no actual criminal
charges attached to them so strong so
powerful what's the real reason answer
plus he's doing this well she'll have to
cat it out of the bag yesterday this
clip 21 she explained because we don't
like Trump because we haven't liked him
for two and a half years it's dancing
Pelosi talking about this but seriously
though it's been going on for 22 months
okay well two and a half years actually
okay so he's been going on two and a
half years in what sense
how how only if you believe that he's
been impeachable since day one so she
just let the cat out of the bag the
entire thing is a sham now why are the
Democrats who focused in on impeachment
they keep
keep just saying it out loud and they're
saying the quiet part out loud basically
they're focused on impeachment because
they believe they're gonna lose in 2020
and if they don't impeach Trump will win
and if they do and if Trump does win and
is not impeach they're gonna claim that
the election was stolen and so they are
setting up this this basic choice
between either we impeach him and then
we win or we don't impeach him and then
he seals the election either way the
Democrats got to claim that the things
illegitimate so here's Eric's Wow well
when he's not threatening to nuke gun
owners in the United States is not
farting on national TV that was not him
it was Chris Matthews moving a mug guys
it was not the flatulence of Duke Nukem
here's Eric swallow that not only Donald
Trump acts corruptly but that when you
show courage and act against him you can
stop him it's actually the only way to
extinguish his corrupt ways if unchecked
my colleagues Donald Trump does not get
better he gets worse
he gets more corrupt and we can't wait
till the next election to hold him
accountable not when he is trying to rig
the next election okay meanwhile Jim
Jefferies saying the same thing he says
you know Americans that this is so
self-defeating he says Americans should
decide elections outcomes
so we're impeaching so why not wait till
the election the implication obviously
is that if there is an election in 2020
that involves Donald Trump it will not
be legitimate this is such a bad game
Democrats are playing there outright
saying we can't beat Trump at the ballot
box we fear and thus we are just going
to push forward with impeachment decide
the outcome of our elections is it the
Russians the Chinese the Ukrainians or
the American people it should be the
American people and that's why we're
here at this moment and so let's have a
serious discussion about it
and stop attacking Americans who refuse
to bend the knee to this president okay
so we can't have a dictator we have to
have elections also we're going to throw
this
so we can't have an election referendum
on him Karen bass also let the the cat
out of the bag the congresswoman she
says listen you know what if Trump wins
again will impeach him again we'll just
keep him heating him is anyone under the
wild misimpression at this point that
the Democrats care at all about the
basis upon which they are impeaching
Trump is it clear to you that they're
doing this because they fear him in 2020
because they've been talking about
impeaching him since day one Pelosi just
said they've been working on this thing
for two years for 22 months here is
Karen bass yes but I don't think it
would be exactly the same and here's why
because even though we're impeaching him
you know now there's still a number of
court cases there's a ton of information
that could come forward for example we
could get his bank records and found and
find out that he's owned a hundred
percent by the Russians so you are
absolutely right in your scenario but
the only thing I would say slightly
different is is that it might not be the
same articles of impeachment because the
odds are we'd have a ton more
information okay so this thing is not
going to end right it's never going to
end is it they're just gonna keep trying
to impeach Trump according to according
to Karen bass how seriously should we
take all of us I take it about as
seriously as Democrat congressman
ceedric Richmond who apparently was
watching golf in the middle of the
yesterday I take it with the same level
of thrill as this Congress person mr.
new goose votes no miss Mike bath miss
Macbeth votes no mr. Stanton no mr.
Stanton votes no misty no no miss Dean
votes no mr. McArthur Powell no misma
carcel Powell votes no mr. Escobar no
miss Escobar vote is going on as the
vote is going on he's watching golf I'm
with that Congress person that Congress
person for Speaker of the House because
that's how seriously we should take all
of this it's all nonsense it's all
stupidity meanwhile President Trump he
is moving closer to a reelection victory
and the reason is because he is getting
some of the key issues off the table and
he's doing it now so President Trump is
going to sign today a new trade deal
with the Chinese he has settled on the
outline of at least a first stage trade
deal with the Chinese
apparently Trump has announced there
will be a 50% reduction in the tariffs
that he isn't that he's imposed on
September 1st which covers about 110
billion dollars of Chinese goods the
duties will go from 15% to 7.5% there's
already a 25% tariff on 250 billion
dollars in goods that he imposed in 2018
that's gonna stay for now but he says
that this is the beginning of a larger
settlement with China the de-escalation
with China well it may not actually be
great policy in the long run because the
United States needs to be
confrontational with China in order to
get them to do what we want in order to
get them to liberalize they've been
retrenching they've been using the free
markets to enrich themselves and then to
use that against the free markets and
then to use that against free countries
okay well it may be better policy to
treat China as an overt enemy at this
point in terms of trumps reelection if
he does that there's a better chance
that the Chinese sink the economy by
selling some of America's bonds on the
open market a month before the election
tank the economy and throw it to whoever
the Democrat is so Trump ironing out
this thing or at least de-escalating
before the election is quite smart
politically it's what he needs to do
according to the New York Times the
United States has settled on final terms
of a partial trade deal with China
several people familiar with the
negotiations said a development that
could ease tensions between the world's
largest economies just days before the
long-running trade war is set to
escalate Trump met with top economic
advisors on Thursday afternoon at the
White House where the president agreed
to significant reductions on tariffs he
has placed on three hundred sixty
billion dollars of Chinese goods in
return for China's commitment to
purchase American farm products and make
other concessions as part of the
agreement the president is expected to
announce he will delay or cancel tariffs
on a hundred and sixty billion dollars
of consumer products from China that
were scheduled to go into effect on
Sunday Trump had foreshadowed this
Thursday morning he tweeted getting very
close to a big deal with China they
wanted and so do we
Michael Pillsbury China scholar at the
Hudson Institute he said this is
historic breakthrough and he attributed
this to Trump having a good relationship
with President Xi Jinping who is in fact
a dictator Trump was agreeing to
rollback some of the terrorists he had
imposed on China in exchange for Beijing
bolstering its annual purchases of
American products to about fifty billion
dollars next year also China is supposed
to enforce stronger protections for
American intellectual property open its
markets to American financial
institutions and commit to greater
transparency surrounding the management
of its currency so it's a good deal for
it for present
Trump at least in so far as the politics
it's good for the economy as well free
trade is always better for the economy
and a foreign policy front is it a great
idea to make deals with China my general
opinion is no but from a markets
perspective it's gonna help the economy
and that of course is very big for
president Trump getting that issue off
the table helps him a lot
another issue he's gotten off the table
which again on a on a policy level I
disagree with it but on a political
level he needed to do before the
election top congressional negotiators
said on Thursday they had reached a deal
in principle to approve 1.3 trillion
dollars in federal spending for 2020
probably averting a government shutdown
next week the Republicans keep making
these deals with Democrats to spend up
the wazoo they never take a strong
position on spending and that's terrible
it's also terrible the American people
are not ready to take strong positions
on spending and are much more sanguine
about spending a trillion dollars into
the red every single year then they
would be about making any cuts to to the
programs that would actually require the
cuts in order to get us close to fiscal
sanity with that said a government
shutdown would not be good for President
Trump leading up to the elections and
that's another Domino that he has
knocked down in advance of the election
also Trump following the Boris Johnson
model he is now embracing more more big
government policies Boris Johnson is not
a small government guy he's a big
government guys just the competitive
labor he's a small government guy Trump
is sort of the same in the United States
Trump yesterday came out in favor of
paid family leave a policy which really
should be left to the private sector but
again he is trying to aim directly at
those suburban moms that he has lost
because of his personality so here's
Trump pushing that yesterday but
American families are coming first with
more women working today than ever
before we now have a historic
opportunity to enact long overdue
reforms it's time to pass paid family
leave and expand access to quality
[Music]
[Applause]
now that's not a policy I like but it is
a smart political policy because a big
spending is always smart political
policy Trump is actually considering
skipping the debates which is not a bad
idea honestly because well the Democrats
would paint that as a form of cowardice
the fact is that the moderator is going
to attack from now in a in reality
Trump's not gonna skip the debates if
there is a if there is a moderator who
is the anti Trump Trump's going to
attack the moderator and it's not gonna
go poorly for him he did it to great
success last time around it is also true
that Trump is quite pithy in debate he
doesn't have a lot to say he's not gonna
give you a booty judge smooth the answer
on any policy but he's cutting and he's
biting and he says things like me
encapsulated in 30-second sound bites
because the number of people who
actually engage with all nine hours of
these debates is fairly low nonetheless
Trump is apparently discussing with his
advisors the possibility of sitting out
general election debates in 2020 because
of his misgivings about the Commission
that oversees them Trump has told his
advisors he does not trust the
Commission on presidential debates the
nonprofit that sponsors the debates
which is right in the moderators that
they picked for the debates in the past
have generally been awful less of a
concern for Trump then who will emerge
as the Democratic nominee is which media
personality will be chosen as the debate
moderator perfectly fair he's not afraid
of Biden he's not afraid of war and he's
not afraid of Sanders he is afraid that
the moderator is going to spend the
entire debate attacking and you saw this
in 2012 when Candy Crowley openly lied
about Mitt Romney on stage and Barack
Obama in order to help Barack Obama so
good for Trump to at least going in with
his eyes wide open the president's
advisers declined to comment on what
their plan was for the debates one
senior advisor to the president seems to
wince the question said it was not
something advisers were prepared to
discuss until next year and again are
the debates gonna help him well they're
opposed um last last election cycle
saying that Hillary won the debates
didn't help her one iota
now the key for Trump is going to be can
he contained the Trump e10 key contained
the Trump enos because if Trump
campaigns on the same premise as his
first campaign commercial which is you
may not like me as a person but I'm
doing a lot of good stuff for the
country and then you can minimize all
the times that he's in the news doing
stuff that annoys people he'll win but
if the election is about Trump it front
makes the election but the only person
who can defeat Trump at this point is
Trump because the
do not have much in the chamber I mean
that there's there's there's no ammo in
that chamber so is it very helpful to
president Trump that he is attacking
Greta Sundberg the 16 year old proxy for
the far left views on climate change is
that like a super smart move
so yesterday Trump tweeted out so
ridiculous Greta must work on her anger
management problem then go to a good
old-fashioned movie with a friend chill
Greta chilled now listen do I find that
funny yeah I do because she's a public
figure when the fact is that her outrage
has been the the subject that has
launched a thousand think pieces and
then the Trump campaign put out a
graphic of the time Person of the Year
it was a picture of Greta Thun Berg
standing by the ocean
they took trump's head and just and then
just pasted it under Greta thunderbirds
body and then it says Donald Trump the
power of promises kept the CNN of course
went nuts over this why would Trump
attack write it because Trump always
attacks because that's what he does man
and listen for you guys to play shocked
at this point is just silly we all get
it is it smart politically yeah it's not
particularly smart politically but it is
very Trumpy now as I say if Trump would
like to win then the best thing that he
can do at this point is to minimize the
Trump II because we all get it right
everybody who likes that likes it
there's nobody in the middle who's like
yeah you know what now that he tweeted
out a picture of himself with his head
on granteth on burns body totally in
before I was on the fence now that we
have that picture of trumps head I'm
Greta thunder Berg's body I've totally
changed my mind I'm vote Trump all the
way I don't think so
that doesn't mean you Adam you got to
make the goofiness completely go away
but you have to channel it toward a
purpose you got to channel the goofiness
toward a purpose is what Boris Johnson's
did very well in Britain and he's
running again small bulldozers through
walls or the big sign that had brexit on
it ik Donald Trump could do that sort of
thing and enjoy it and it would work for
him but it's got to be connected with
policy it can't just be him being like I
credit n brakes the way she's the worst
anger management like I don't see a
purpose to that okay time for a thing
that you know what enough things I like
we're gonna do a thing that I hate
there is an insane piece of the
Washington Post today a fully crazy
piece at the Washington Post today the
way that the Washington Post in the New
York Times cover anti-semitism
demonstrates how how they do not take
anti-semitism seriously an incredible
incredible obvious way so the New York
Times is a piece today in which they
quote a bunch of reform rabbis who don't
know a lot about Judaism or care much
about Israel talking about how president
from signing an executive order to
defend Jews on campus is very very bad
shocked are there that's what the New
York Times does The Washington Post has
an even more incredible pieces a
reported piece by Wesley Lowery Kevin
Armstrong Indiana Paul and it's titled
Jersey City grapples with ramifications
of shooting at kosher market the entire
piece is about the roiling tensions
inside Jersey City that led to the
shooting of a bunch of Jews at a kosher
supermarket and what could have been
much worse as I mentioned earlier on the
program there's tape that now shows that
these shooters were attempting to break
in next door and there there were 50
schoolchildren upstairs so this thing
could have been a sandy hook style
massacre by black Hebrew Israelites
against Jews well the the Washington
Post principies that they would never
print about anything else if there were
a child after Charleston after the South
Carolina massacre in a black church by
white supremacists whether ever have
been a piece about the roiling racial
tensions that led to so much white anger
after the El Paso shooting would there
have been a piece about how increased
Hispanic immigration had led the white
population to increase it to anger and
led to additional conflict of course not
because everybody understood that white
supremacist shootings are evil and
unrepresentative of the surrounding
population but and certainly are not
justified by anything that is happening
in the world but this piece from the
Washington Post basically attempts to
lend justification to the shooting it's
pretty astonishing here is what it says
the JC kosher supermarket sits on a
block that appears the portrait of an
American cultural melting pot across the
street is a Catholic parish a few
storefronts away in one direction is an
African hair braiding salon in the other
a mosque the entire block rest a few
miles from Ellis Island settled in the
shadow of the Statue of Liberty yet the
market and the ultra-orthodox families
that frequent it also nods to a more
complicated if equally American story
that of a poor black community that
after decades of underinvestment has
seen away
of redeployment and new arrivals
remember this is an article about the
murder of Jews at a kosher supermarket
by black Hebrew Israelites that's what
this article is about okay and can you
imagine that sentence can you imagine
that sentence by the way we're showing
some of the tape right now you can see
the lead shooter takes a look at the
door they view if you run it back and
see the lead shooter takes a look at the
door that is the school and then quickly
turns and enters the supermarket see
look right there that's the turn that
could have been a lot worse but that
sentence from the Washington Post yet
the market and the ultradox orth
ultra-orthodox families that frequented
also nod to a more complicated if
equally American story that of a poor
black community that after decades of
underinvestment has seen a wave of
redeployment and new arrivals I'm gonna
change that language for El Paso right
yet the Walmart and the Hispanic
families that frequent it also nod to a
more complicated if equally American
story that of a poor white community
that after decades of underinvestment
has seen a wave of redeployment in new
arrivals if that sentence appeared in
the Washington Post he would get the
Washington Post boycotted and rightfully
so because guess what doesn't justify
the mass murder of people on the basis
of their ethnicity or their religion
under investment in the local community
gentrification this is insane and the
Washington Post continues along these
lines they see more than 100 Jewish
families have moved here in recent years
fleeing astronomical housing costs in
Brooklyn settling into affordable homes
across the Hudson in the heart of the
historic black community while their
arrival prompted fears that would be
tension between Hasidic arrivals in the
black residents who have been here for
generations many who have moved here say
they have found friendly neighbors who
made them feel at home then on Tuesday a
horrific attack threatened to shatter
that goodwill oh it was the it was the
attack that threatened the goodwill we
have tape from directly outside the site
of the shooting of black residents of
the city talking about how the shooting
was a good thing again the media
coverage of this is so is so invested in
the intersectional politics of the left
it's insane we have to turn the the real
story about the Jersey City shooting not
into a problem of two black anti-semites
murdering Jews and leave that to a
broader conversation of anti-semitism
that exists in every community and
aren't there problems of anti-semitism
in parts of the black
particularly in Brooklyn in New Jersey
we're not going to have that discussion
instead we're going to talk about
gentrification and how said of Jews
moving into the neighborhood is creating
all of this turmoil again imagine if the
Washington Post in the aftermath of
Charleston wrote a story about how black
families moving into white neighborhoods
was causing ethnic tensions that led to
a shooting
you'd be like wait what what but that's
what this Washington Post story
effectually does it's crazy
according to the Washington Post as
investigators continue to probe the
attack which comes amid a rise in
anti-semitic violence nationally this
city is grappling with whether the
attacks reflect underlying ethnic
tensions locally and fears it could
spark new ones
well maybe you might want to talk with
black leaders locally about why they
think that this thing happened and
whether in fact the polls that show
outsized black anti-semitism in the
United States are reflective of a dearth
of leadership in some parts of the black
community you would certainly do that if
the races were reversed if this has been
a Jew who went and shot up a black
church you would get a lot of talk about
our rabbis from the pulpit being racist
is the the ethnic tension between Jews
and blacks are those the fault of Jews
right I mean that's what you would get
now you're getting Jews moved into the
neighborhood and that's causing ethnic
tension like this the coverage is just
maddening it's maddening and pathetic
and it's this article would never have
been written about anybody except for
Jews nobody except for Jews would have
this article written about them they
literally have the articles about
gentrification the development of
suburbs in the 1950s and 60s led to an
exodus of most of the area's white
residents later followed by many
middle-class black families once the
Fair Housing Act empowered them to
pursue suburban living as well the loss
of moneyed residents and their
businesses was coupled with the
departure of manufacturing jobs which
were relocated to the south and later
overseas leaving behind an
under-resourced urban core of poor black
and brown people left to fend for
themselves as violence and drugs spread
so in other words if we just cut a few
more government checks and if we added
more to the redistributed of burden of
the American people and made this area
richer then that would have kept the
Jews out then you wouldn't have this
problem in the first place well done
Washington Post well done insane stuff
already we'll be back here with two
additional hours later today we'll get
into the mailbag
we sort of ran out of time today but if
you don't subscribe to get the
additional two hours you're not going to
get those two additional hours this is
why you should go subscribe right now we
have special Christmas and Hanukkah
deals available go check it out right
now otherwise we'll see you here next
week i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director Pavel white house key
edited by Adam Sai events audio is mixed
by micro Meena hair and makeup is by JL
alvera production assistant Nick Sheehan
the Ben Shapiro show is a daily wired
production copyright daily wire 20 19 on
the Matt Walsh show we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
[Music]
you